We use the Gradle Wrapper way back
the start of this class to run our
first task.
Before we had even installed Gradle.
That's a cool party trick, but
the real strength of the wrapper
is that you can put your build
tool under version control.
So everyone building your project is
building it with the exact same tool.
The Gradle Wrapper is composed of four
files, a jar, our properties file, and
a pair of scripts, a shell script for
UNIX and Mac, and a batch script for
Windows.
When you pass a command to one of these
scripts, it'll first check if Gradle
is installed, download it if necessary,
then execute your command.
A wrapper can be created by running
the built -in wrapper task.
Here we go, let's give it a try.
And here we see the files of the Gradle
Wrapper, the two build scripts, and
then inside the Gradle directory
we'll find the gradlewrapper.jar and
the gradlewrapperdir.properties.
We can now run our Gradle
build using the wrapper.
We use the wrapper identically to
how we would use the Gradle command.
Let's get our task list.
Oops, looks like we don't have
this version of Gradle installed.
Since this was our first time using
the wrapper, it went ahead and
downloaded the appropriate Gradle
distribution, and cached it locally.
We can also explicitly configure
what version of Gradle we want
the wrapper to use by setting the Gradle
version property of the wrapper task.
Let's change the version to 2.2 and
run the wrapper task again.
Now if we use this new wrapper to get
the task list, it'll have to download
Gradle again because we don't
already have version 2.2.
If we run gradle --version to see
which we're actually using here,
looks like we were using version
2.2 just like we asked for.
Configuration options of
the Gradle Wrapper is stored in this
Gradle Wrapper properties file.
We've got it opened up down here.
As you can see, what URL to get
Gradle from is defined here.
Is currently using Gradle version 2.2,
just like we set from the build file.
Let's change this back to 2.3.
Now if we try running Gradlew version
again, we see we're back on version 2.3.
This is a really important feature, as
it allows us to centrally control what
version of Gradle is used
to build our project.
In practice, the Gradle Wrapper files,
including the scripts, jar, and
properties file,
will be committed to source control.
This serves two main functions.
First, it means that everything that
is needed to get up and running with
the development of our project is
included in the source repository.
Second, it means that the Gradle
version is also version control,
which eliminates the possibility that
a developer encounters problems with
the build due to using
the wrong version of Gradle.